[Music]
[Music]
my name is Alice Holman and I play tenor
smith-corona with the Boston typewriter
Orchestra the Boston typer - orchestra
is an ensemble for typewriter invoice
some of us have musical backgrounds some
of us don't several of our members play
in bands currently I haven't touched
much of anything except for typewriters
since playing the trombone in high
school we play a wide variety of
typewriters from some small portable
models all the way up to some relatively
large desk models a lot of what we do in
building up songs is really exploring
what different sounds we can get out of
the typewriter and how we can
incorporate them into a song for example
you have the the key makes it of F a
basic clack sound but then you have the
the shift that moves a lot of mechanics
and make somewhat of a bass sound then
you also have the the roller that gets a
get sort of a mechanical ratchet sound
to it and then all of them we can work
with the the carriage return for like
that you know the standard sweep e sound
to it as our name suggests the Boston
typewriter Orchestra is Boston based but
we've actually played all over New
England
most of the typewriters are 50 60 70
years old usually in our hands we see
two to three years of lifespan we feed
on them pretty hard when we started out
in 2004 we were we were a bunch of guys
getting together and kind of banging on
typewriters we get that we're kind of
weird it's a little bit of a wacky idea
but we've discovered that this makes
some legitimate music and you know it
can be a real serious endeavor we have
true songs that come together and people
seem to really enjoy them and as long as
we still are entertaining people we're
gonna stay out there typing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very often people think it's gonna be
funny and then they realize it's not
really we really do music it's not
impossible to make music with vegetables
[Music]
my name is Susanna got Naya and then I'm
a member of the vegetable orchestra the
orchestra exists since 18 years now if
there's instrument roasted tomato
because you can do sound with tomatoes
but it will be messy for sure we go
shopping on the market first we choose
all the vegetables there we have three
kinds of instruments one is the ready
mate you can just buy it at the market
and play it it's like the pepper it's
cold it's ready already and then there
are the simple instruments like with one
cut or some cuts to get it like that
then with the more complex instruments
we have some that work like normal
instruments you know the pumpkin is the
bass drum and the sound of the pumpkin
is really important after shopping we go
to the venue and start to build
instruments all in all it takes 2 to 3
hours to build all the instruments for
everybody and then we start with the
soundcheck and since we have new
instruments each time we have to have a
very long soundcheck
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a lot of different musical
influences in the orchestra since
they're really many people everybody's
interested in different things we make
the soup during the building process of
the vegetable instruments with the
remaining vegetables when we serve it to
the audience after the concert and it's
also after hearing and seeing us and
smelling the vegetables which will be
intense in there because it's so small
this theater and then you can also eat
it you never get it out of your head
anymore if you're in the orchestra to
look vegetables in another way every
place in the world sounds unique these
sound scapes tell us a story about that
place they tell us the ways in which
global warming is beginning to change
the natural soundscape
[Music]
just before the Sun rises at first light
is the dawn chorus the birds begin to
sing and the insects and the amphibians
and that's the time of day to go out and
listen I'm a soundscape
ecologist that record animals for a
living
this is Sugarloaf State Park every
spring I can probably be found there
once a week recording in the same spot
using the same kind of equipment so that
I can repeat these recordings over and
over again and compare them and I have
quite a archive of material which shows
over time this habitat has been changing
pretty radically there's a result of
global warming and the California
drought the first recording made in 2004
shows a very robust habitat with a
signature of a stream in 2014 things
were changing radically it was already
the second year of a major drought in
California and in 2015 we had what I
call a Silent Spring over 50% of my
collection comes from habitats that are
so radically altered they're either
altogether silent or no longer be heard
in their original form here's an example
from Costa Rica
[Music]
that's before logging this is after
same spot this is a coral reef the new
allez-vous and Fiji part of it is dying
and part of it is still living here's
what the living part sounds like here's
what the dying part sounds like hardly
any fish sounds
we really don't know what this means in
the long run in the short run were
beginning to lose these soundscapes
because habitats are just changing so
radically and we're partly to blame for
them when I first began to record almost
fifty years ago I would go out into the
field and just put on a pair of
earphones and sit and listen because it
made me feel good it made me aware of
the living world around me and so I want
to do anything that does that for me
[Music]
I'm sure someone were to look inside my
window while I'm playing they probably
would have no idea what's going on in
here to watch a theremin being played
looks really strange my name is Pamela
and Stickney and one of the instruments
I'd love to play is severa man like what
the hell was that in fact I don't know
so the theremin is a synthesizer and
it's a synthesizer that's not controlled
with the use of a keyboard like a piano
I'm controlling the pitches with my left
hand and this hand is just the
articulation hands the volume
[Music]
it's controlled without any physical
contact and you can make it like a birds
[Music]
the really big challenge with the
instrument is its reacting not just to
my hands and how they're moving in my
fingers it's sensitive as well into my
whole body I've recorded on an album of
David Burns Grace Jones the Indigo Girls
it's such a new instrument still that
there's nobody who's going to stand
there and say you're not doing it the
way it's supposed to be done I don't
think there's anything else like it it
doesn't relate to anything else I've
ever played
[Music]
I'm the first woman to graduate with a
doctorate from Juilliard and now I play
the toy piano life works in mysterious
ways
I have transformed the toy piano into a
rail instrument to play at the Toy Barn
oh well you have to practice on it every
bit as hard as you would on a normal
piano in fact I think you have to work
even harder because the action is so
primitive you can make it sound
beautiful you can make it sound
convincing it's a bit like going down
the rabbit hole and taking your audience
with you way back down this Avenue to
your childhood days what a skeptical
person comes to a toy piano concert that
I give I'm able to turn him around it's
a whole extended family now of people
into toy pianos
it's a fearless little band and we're
willing to stick their necks out for
toys
[Music]
[Music]